it's Thursday the 26th of September you
bad [ __ ] greetings from podcast
Ville the Church of what's happened now
is brought to you by my bookie listen if
we're going on week three week four I
don't [ __ ] know if you find the
yardstick on the street but you pick it
up or what you keep walking obviously
you'd bend over and pick it up so why do
you keep picking winners and you're not
betting let me tell you something
there's no more [ __ ] calling your
bookie and talking encoded the gray
cavalier I got the answer to all your
[ __ ] dilemmas my bookie
listen it's easy and they pay when you
win let's face it we're you're betting
is as important as who you betting on
correct
if you try to bet on the NFL baseball
MMA whatever my bookies got it so do me
a favor right now double your first
deposit today use promo code Church CH
you are CH to get 100% bonus on your
initial deposit up to $1,000 who's
better than you nobody visit my bookie
dot AG today
that's my bookie dot AG and don't forget
to use promo code Church when creating
your account to claim the bonus and
tomorrow check my Instagram at Matt
flavors world I'm dropping a video from
my bookie to teach you a few things the
church is also brought to you by upstart
listen it's very easy to get into debt
but it's even harder to get out of debt
especially when your credit score is not
great
upstart could help you upstart goes
beyond the traditional credit score your
upstart interest rate is based on your
education and job history
not your credit score listen it's time
to consolidate your debt and put it into
one monthly payment would up start today
right now see why upstart is ranked
number one in that category
with over three hundred businesses on
Trustpilot Harry the upstart com slash
Church CH you are CH to find out how low
your Upstate rate is checking your rate
only takes a few minutes upstart com
slash Church the church is also brought
to you by
personal favorite on it listen starting
today
right now when I talk to you if you
order a 30 count or a 90 kind of half a
brain or the powder they're gonna send
your raffle ticket it's gonna
automatically win like a coupon or you
might win a kettlebell or something like
that but it also registered for the
island experience you'll enjoy what's
the AMA experience for days in Austin
Texas they fly you down there you stay
at the haunted house they train you to
give you one-on-one to one-on-ones they
take you to a barbecue joint they give
you 500 hours cash plus they give you
total human for one year alpha brain for
one year set of kettlebells Club bells
listen go to audit calm right now press
in church and get your alpha brain right
now that's that flagship product it
works your memory and focus and it's the
way to go go to alikom right now and get
some alpha brain and register take it
into the haunted house lee kick this
[ __ ] meal a lot of love what a
[ __ ] you been able I've been traveling
2006 my face has been on the road every
weekend almost I always do that you did
a lot of the troops and all that stuff
yeah I've been to 67 countries Iraq
Saudi Kuwait Djibouti I've been to Korea
four times almost got beat up but by a
store owner who accused me being too fat
to fit his garments and then I don't I
had to step in and save me from this
Korean man who wanted to beat me down in
this store cheese did you go with Steve
Simone cuz I know he did a lot of those
tours no I've always done like lady
tours a lot of lady tours and you really
like him I do I've seen pictures of you
shooting guns I I didn't hit anything I
was like oh what'd I hit and the guy was
like nothing ma'am you didn't hit a
thing I'll don't forget like when I
first met you you know I mean you're
still very beautiful and I'm bumping
into you another friend of mine you I
hear we're going over there to do tours
not my problems feel so bad for these
soldiers my tits over there but she's a
backbreaker
no [ __ ] AWOL let's take that one
[ __ ] soldier in Apocalypse Now and
when they landed I don't want to go I
don't want to go through them off the
helicopter
those are guys when you leave I'm coming
with you back though there's you kept
going some way she must be gone already
watch with me I never banged one I never
banged one but there was one in a
commissary where I was like oh yeah
that's the one I'd sit on his face
that's gone are you allowed do they tell
you not to I mean you just don't I don't
I don't know if any other ladies did but
I don't want to like sneak off and a
base in Iraq with my helmet my Kevlar
vest and just pound some stranger seems
like not appropriate when you do these
things are you scared at all anything
I was only scared and so date like when
you do Iraq you're on US military bases
and installations and they do all the
clear ends and you're flying in
Blackhawks and there's like dudes that
are you know they have a bunch of guns
on them but when you go to Saudi you're
just like with this Korean dude who's
your MWR rep taking you to downtown
Riyadh and then I Kate the some guy came
up to me in downtown Riyadh and he's
like you steel I've cut your hands off
and I was like oh you can just say that
to a white face lady in Saudi so I was a
little scared I was a little more scared
because you're not on base and they
can't have uniformed soldiers with you
at all
so you're just whatever I'm WR wrap you
get shooting clubs and then mix in um I
mean I've traveled throughout I've done
like shows in Europe and Australia and
Southeast Asia and then every state here
I'm always pedaling my dick jokes from
town to town but every state I think I'm
missing a couple I'm missing Hawaii you
do all those I've done them all I've
done them all you never don't know why
no okay I did I know I don't know Mexico
Texas Oklahoma I don't think I've been
to Arkansas okay don't some weird shows
there's no happy I did know I did a
little yeah there you go
did a little rock the funny ball I think
you'd be surprised if you go through and
you're like I think I probably have a
some point near life I knew I was close
years ago and there were just a couple
states missing but now because I even
went to Alaska ya know I did a little
askin but it was my last one charlie
[ __ ] I did some weird theater
but I think like some El DeBarge cover
band was in town and we got upstaged by
some weird cover band that our show is a
real stinker it's a fun town I want to
do some dog sleds and the fish is
[ __ ] delicious yeah right now there's
a place right across that grills fishery
it was still flapping these people they
were white that would just cook the big
fat dudes a special [ __ ] day when I
remember that I went up there with a
stripper okay
I dated a stripper at the time yeah this
is 95 when I went to Alaska 96 I opened
up a todd Jordan he's still dear friend
of mine and we stayed at the condo but
the big attraction was the strip club
there okay because in 95 there was three
women every one man Wow there was some
statistic and those years if you look it
up and they might be the other way
around we were moving to Alaska because
there was tons of [ __ ] yeah and nobody
to flop here what happens when the ships
come in those chicks make 20,000 a night
really yeah when the fishing boats or
the sailors or something just that was
the reputation so I dated a stripper
yeah and half the girl from Seattle at
that time we were living in Seattle
myself Josh wolf a couple of them were
living up there and she was saying that
just how if you live in Seattle oh and I
think up and let's just keep it at
Pacific Northwest I don't get it [ __ ]
you could give you a young man and
you're in shape you get a job on a
fishing for a few months for a few
months it's dangerous work but people
approached me when I lived in Seattle
how does it work make your money and
come back yeah you go out for 30 days
you come back without a note 10 grand
I'm just drawing about that something
that you would not
make if you worked two jobs here yeah
you just went to sixty days and you come
down a cash and then people will just
get addicted it's you know sixty days
twenty thousand dollars you work for
sixty days
yeah you [ __ ] in a little room you smell
feet you sell ads but you sacrifice you
home you know if you watch that show
what's that
king crab fishermen Deadliest Catch
Deadliest Catch yeah that was an option
for men for the strippers of Seattle
just wait it out they would get flown up
to Alaska the club would come to Seattle
you know give me the ten on how these
[ __ ] because they want when the ships
come in whoever it whoever whatever was
whether it was the big fishing boat so
the service I don't know what it is
don't quote me they wanted the chicks to
be ready oh yeah you're all horned up if
you've been on a boat with dudes
catching fish on cash yeah it was like
three the strip club was like a
downstairs but it looked like an old
hooker house like they would have VIP
rooms and then they would stand outside
it was a pretty neat place and don't
even wait like an old froth oh yeah it
was like an old brothel style but that's
all I remember from [ __ ] Alaska Joe
Crowley's just dying I just got some
boots that's all I remember there were
cities just I bought a pair of but some
winter boots so yeah as people have been
doing it a while for a new comic do you
guys wish you had spent more time
traveling in all these places because
not many people get to go to every 50
state like that's like a weird thing
that comics get to do and it doesn't
seem that weird but like do you wish you
had experience more of these places or
you just know I feel like when I I mean
it's if it's a good city if I'm going to
some [ __ ] you're like I'm just gonna
hide out my Courtyard Marriott and eat
snacks off my tits all day but I feel
like if you're in a good city you always
go and because most people want to show
you around if specially if you're going
to a comedy club or you're doing a
military thing you're like climbing on
planes or there have you run with the
dart the dogs that drug dogs that bite
people like I feel like you're always
involved in some shenanigans on the road
I don't feel I feel like I've done a ton
of [ __ ] okay I think I've laid down
enough in the last 17 years I really
like you yeah and I know that when you
travel you really enjoy yourself now you
yourself have met other people that you
know they travel so that they seem
interesting yeah those [ __ ] I
don't like I just like travel I like to
travel
but how I'm scared of international
travel just on a personal level are you
don't trust it what did you make that so
the chickens I would need food oh I
start myself in those countries I don't
like is there anywhere like that you
would want to go I love to go to England
okay
really I love to see like Birmingham
England I want to see like the students
out when they recorded Pink Floyd albums
I kept on large stuff I'd love to go to
the motherland the island okay I'd love
to go to Israel and go to the wall and
pray and meet some hard don't [ __ ]
around Halloween plan a trip for you to
Ireland in the UK I think I should go I
got no passport number I got 89 in
felonies me the travel I could travel
okay but it's gonna cost me and a year
reports in downtown and Bayport how can
at the end of the week how much do I
really want to travel not not much when
people travel the first thing I say
though is how is the food you know it's
not England's kind of bullshitting I
don't trust about I'll trust people be
gobble anything you give me a food car
you give me a man with dirty hands
luckily whatever like I never get sick I
see why I think what Dane used to go
with the chubby little gay dude yeah you
know that [ __ ] drives me crazy I walk
down a stress your chickens leg in
barbecue sauce I'm on a plane
yeah I'll try and get creeped out by all
that stuff but I will tell you my
personal opinion on something and will
you
give me a lot I love the United States
of America and when I became a comic the
thought of going to someplace is always
like you have these predisposition like
oh I saw this on TV Alabama they hate
black people and you can't be out after
midnight whatever you may think and
today one of the things that makes me
the happiest about being a comic is that
before I could look you in the face and
oh my god
Kahn last year what would have were all
these jerk-offs in Hollywood gonna be a
Beiser
whatever the [ __ ] these before you
allowed to go to Ibiza I want you to go
to North Dakota okay
I only need one South Dakota I've been
you know like northern many northern
Minnesota where people off go fishing
and offer you that holla holla that fish
that they have that special but then
there man that know what's the what
Wisconsin as a fish and they'll tell you
you know to all those places and I had
the best times in my life there was no
cocaine involved later on that night up
with the bartender or something but one
of the things that makes me proudest
about being a comic is it I can look you
in the eye entail this is a [ __ ]
beautiful country and the people that
live in it I got with the Texas couple
we see on Texas people [ __ ]
Texas people Texas barbecue then you go
to Pittsburgh and they they got a
certain flavor then you go to Chicago in
Chicago people are alive Jack Mike you
know they're alive and then you go to
San Francisco and everybody's kind of
weird and hippie-ish so every place has
this identity so the country's gorgeous
like I've got coke and some Snake River
South Dakota the one Mexican dish wash
we made eye contact when it was all over
you can say yeah how strangers fall in
love in the night I knew he was a drug
dealer
he is the only Mexican at the South
Dakota we made eye contact when he came
by said como stai he was all excited
you're Latino yeah he took me to his
house for dinner
he was the only Spanish guy like a
12-mile region he got stuck up there cuz
he his wife was in the army
okay so he moved from like New York he
saw me invited me to his house got me
weed got me coke and feta means I mean I
stood you know and it's a [ __ ] weird
story but it just goes to show you
people everybody's great around me I
feel like people everybody has the same
set of wants and needs instead of
emotions and you want to feel it loved
and accepted no matter where you go but
that's how I feel about other countries
other than the language in France no I
mean France is a little snooty like I
was in Paris one time and I asked how
far the walk was to the Eiffel Tower and
the whole and that she was a it was like
an expensive hotel I'm like [ __ ] just
answer the question she was like I do
not know I did not know how fast you
walk and I was like ah what about this
like a medium pace how long do you think
it'll take me at a medium pace you dumb
couse like I feel like France is a
little snotty but most places like
Mediterraneans very warm Italians are
very warm Swiss are nice people like I
feel like Malaysia was lovely and a
lovely uber driver in Malaysia like you
have conversations with these people and
everybody wants to see their kids do
well in one's love and wants a better
life for whatever knitly are the men
handsy they're a little grabby I gotta
grab they're real grabby right there and
when he goes or no go do good there
little man he's Italian yeah it was like
wish we [ __ ] they touch your
wife they always what they're more
aggressive and I find because we I own a
bar in Florence Italy with my husband
and ours is like the non rapey bar
apparently there's like a few Raby bars
where Italian like older Italian dudes
just kind of lurk outside and wait for
the college students to like come you
know stumbling out find out who's the
weak one wait for it yeah that is crazy
yeah I didn't know you owned the bar
yeah we run a bar and restaurant in
Florence you do comedy there now yeah
you like arty
like I just said I just sit and drink I
drink a lot more and what kind of food
uh
merican fair cuz there's like 15,000
American students the get lucky bar and
restaurant in Florence this is an
American bar you don't have a publisher
man now we don't know we have a fried
macaroni and cheese balls
I love these potato skins it's always
some type of pride [ __ ] Polish people
tough you never seen like the the
organization of Polish concerned
citizens
no no lobbying outside then I come
Barnes and Nobles because they sell
Polish jokes they're just taking a
hockey sticks out a lot and there's a
hundred polish joke books nobody gives a
[ __ ] no one polish person has ever
raised their hand
no but black people want reparation and
like how to change a light bulb no [ __ ]
it's still the same every [ __ ] race
is suffered a lot of blood alcoholism
and polish families I feel like I'm just
riddled just chock-full of alcoholics
and our family strong Polish stock it's
crazy cuz my ex-wife was polish you know
I was around the family for six years
and they really rubbed off on me they
were very influential who I am today
the father was self-made I think he went
into the army first didn't like how he
was treated he was polish in like the
40s or 50s and he Jonathan got a job at
Fischer prize to some and then he went
to college he went to the University of
Buffalo because he was so ashamed of how
Polish people were treated they stormed
oh my gosh
which means dumb ass or a donkey or
something like that so you could tell he
always went for intelligence like I met
him right before I went to prison
hmm and he didn't [ __ ] lightly but
the more I got in trouble he wouldn't
pay attention to me but I would always
read
these magazines that he had these Air
Force magazine they would go that were
great they were great articles so we
became kind of tight as I read because
of his love but I got to really mean
them and I understood what his whole
motivation was even like how Polish
people were portrayed yeah and he wanted
to change that you know and that's why
we would laugh and earlier they changed
the name well we get together with the
rest of the family they were they on
that side of the family that changed
their name because they kept the
cruising ski name you know Pat Benatar's
half a [ __ ] oh really
mine's much a check yes like they're
[ __ ] these names a huge it's a lot
it's a lot of but I really respect
publish people because I got I learned a
lot from that family they were the first
second generation polish is something
you know I learned all the dishes I
learned the language that brought my
ex-wife had two brothers that were
world-class skiers but just didn't have
to a Polish yeah they just didn't have
the motivation to they'd rather be on a
roof and drink yeah but I learned
something from them one weekend we all
went skiing yeah and I'm a no-frills
typing I don't I don't like looking like
something you ever go to a comedy show
in the comics got a suit on with
sneakers yeah yeah I hate I've always
hated outfits that's why I don't like
the hats yeah it's okie and the earring
I still got the same hairdo I had in
high school there's no markings and you
know and I got arrested they got nut
they always look for that one scar the
my scar there's nothing no I don't need
for you to know who the [ __ ] I am by
putting two earrings in my eyeballs do
you remember that guy that it was a
comic that used to bring his own
microphone and he would unscrew and then
put like an old-timey microphone for
essentially open mics
you're like what is this guy I can deal
with his life do you remember that time
I remember the story but it's this guy
zone my gold [ __ ] microphone for a
three minutes spot but I remember my
brother-in-law's took me
we weren't brother-in-law's yet we were
just I was dating their sister and I
went to Breckenridge with them one day
was like a two-hour drive from bold or
something I think I don't know
and we went to this tournament when we
got there all these people had on I
swear to god it was beautiful
they had on suits and expensive goggles
and the [ __ ] [ __ ] helmet it was
1987 it's 1986 and he gave a [ __ ] about
a bump to the head that I can't remember
I can't take it no more 2000 years
they've been playing football who said
now I hear people I'm gonna shoot
somebody forget there was like I don't
know I could be exaggerating let's say
25 people this expensive gear and
sponsored by my brother was basically
took their sneakers well you know Ruffa
jeans a t-shirt and a [ __ ] flannel
goggles on no no [ __ ] helmet nothing
great
Joe was this name and then polish is
juju yeah if your name is Joe juju or
something like that so he went up to him
broke the record they gave him a trophy
he threw the skis in the back and he got
in his truck and drove over Wham
and he used to drive with a bomb in 1986
he already had a bong in the car and he
bring it down on the water
[Music]
think about I still think about but all
those little things their work ethic
yeah they drank all night that's that's
most of my family like my dad still 64
and like you know that [ __ ] stayed with
my mom even though she yelled at him
every day he's like all right just
couldn't imagine waking up one day
without my
you're like our rights it's that's
admirable I get it
just working just still churning away I
don't give a [ __ ] of you're an alcoholic
as long as you're a functioning
alcoholic if you're a functioning
alcoholic you have no beef with me ah my
mom's my dad doesn't really drink
anymore because of the diabetes but my
mom's a real real Boozer real REO booze
wagon just always starts at 10:00 you
hear the cheap beer skirt in the wallet
in the morning you hear it crack open
how old 64 but her mom died of cirrhosis
of the liver so I feel like it's yeah
they're all real boozy I can't believe I
didn't come up boozy real I'm not a robe
is there a mom could put him away Jay
yeah that's mine like a kid like a case
every two days every day and a half my
mom with breakfast was huh yeah that's
my mom my mom just you hear it crack
I'll be sleeping on the couch and like
oh [ __ ] there goes it's starting early I
everyone has their thing though I think
everybody does have their thing it's
just knowing it seeing if it becomes a
problem
I prefer weed I listen we there's never
been a problem to nobody unless you go
here [ __ ] top with it and you fall
asleep at work or you know it affects
drug test
I don't even I've never even considered
a weed to be anything like like anything
I guess I was a kid like I my
Godfather's loaded and nothing happened
to me with giggle so wait a second
you're telling me that something that
makes you giggle is bad even giggling
yeah I just ordered a McFlurry up $10
ubereats McFlurry that's the Ohio my
guilty thing yeah like I'm just paying
for overpriced McDonald's deliveries
right now I would love especially after
my long drug career I would love to look
people in the eye and say that I'm sober
but I had a hard time when I was
yeah it really won against who I was for
some reason it just bothered me yeah I
did it for a month here a month damn
like I locked up I did it I could do it
it just didn't feel like me so right now
I go you know what I don't need pills I
don't need this I don't need that I like
my reefa name right now this I do like
eight buckets before I got yeah it's a
teddy bear it's the last piece of my my
past I just can't drive I feel like I
just get real weird and paranoid at me
so I can't do bird here
what's the weed legged Emily it's not as
good it's shitty and they roll it with
tobacco which always makes me furious
I'm like why don't you just [ __ ] up
yeah that's bad those Egyptians they
roll the weed with tobacco a piece of
ash in it real strong sturdy broad and
you've never stopped you uh I hope you
have a lot of respect you know nothing
pisses me off one look I'm married I'm
56
I mean don't I wouldn't listen I don't
even want my wife to suck my dick so
when I say this I say this out of pure
honesty and respect nothing bothered me
more wasn't that dude said that women
aren't funny people make that statement
you know because we're all hypocrites
when we say that because we all grew up
on I Love Lucy yeah so right there
you lost shut up don't make that
statement I just do not ever make that
statement around I feel like you can
somebody can not be your sensibility but
if people make like I never understand
how people can hate comics I'm like how
do you hate a person whose sole
intention is so good and all they want
to do is bring joy and happiness to
strangers and sacrifice their life
traveling around the world and to say a
woman's not funny it's like well she's
making she's making people laugh or her
somebody wrote her a check her tax
returns are an indication that that
person is funny I feel like if you're
making money
you're making people laugh so how can
you [ __ ] say that
no it drives me crazy and it's women
like you that have always I don't look
at this [ __ ] these [ __ ] are coming
in that hyung get spots cuz I'm female
I'm just going back how it happened
Croatia
yeah sure on the best soldiers that are
dying to [ __ ] torment yeah I'm doing
weird shows shows wherever I can that's
a proof in the pudding to me and there's
two differences your and I don't like to
say this but it's the truth
you're in a hot category yeah you won
like the sexy Tommy hosted you know so
you were handled differently
mmm so you and I both know you know we
are you know the deal you came into the
club you're great we want to help you a
week later we're calling you for a piece
of ass you don't give him a piece ass
book yeah and there's no more help
what a sad [ __ ] state of affair of
what human being you are no but that
happened so much to women bring another
like I find the trouble now is like if I
want to bring a friend with me another
lady comic they like well we can't have
two ladies on show that's a lady show
and you're like oh I just have to be
alone in the hotel room there's only a
few clubs where you're allowed to bring
your opener as a woman if you want
another woman so you're just lonely like
how can you say a woman's not funny
who's willing to be lonely for 17 years
like I was on the road there were years
it was like 40 42 weekends a year
churning and out don't worry just coming
back on Monday flying back out Tuesday
night just enough time to just enough
time to do laundry and repack with the
way they still could smoke reach yeah
three shows three show Saturdays three
show there's only three places that do
that now
really yeah Tampa desert punchline in
Atlanta does it and st. Louis funny bone
and oh and a nice does it st. Louis just
stopped say nice I will do a midnight
Miami's doing it's hard
Miami and Rob is doing ID they called
three weeks ago it's it's nice should
thank you but no it's only an hour and a
half there's no it's when you've talked
for that long not at all
that third time every level of every
level I don't want the consumer to put
up with that yeah I don't want the
consumer to put up with that again we're
going back to the law of diminishing
returns
how good is Joey gonna be for the third
shell not it's your - how long is Joey
gonna be not only is he tired you're
tired you're standing sheets into the
wind because you started partying on
[ __ ] I want the Guns and Roses
Saturday night my wife and I were
talking about this and I want to clarify
this on the podcast that I was not
trying to be an [ __ ]
but this is reality this was a girl at
the Guns & Roses concert the other night
it just started heart suggested concert
just [ __ ] star she's passed out damn
poor [ __ ] is passed on the cops I'm
okay
I took two pictures over and people got
pissed off at me go help whatever first
off is still my business number two she
had a boyfriend yeah let him she came on
a boyfriend what happened was two things
happened I'll explain to you what happen
because I've been through it the housing
[ __ ] concerts
hey either you started getting high too
early or B you know what happens when
you gonna concert your adrenaline goes
up yeah when you walk into like the
concert that you're a fan of your
adrenaline goes up and after three
Soler's your adrenaline crashes she was
passed out I mean this is Guns and Roses
the Palladium it can't be any louder
it's not like she was playing the
[ __ ] log in with Tyler harmonica this
[ __ ] was out and she passed out with
her boyfriend and her boyfriend got up
and went to another section with other
people and left it huh and I didn't
include that the tweet because I'm not a
crime stopper yeah we get a rogue finger
blasting on my way you don't know it
wasn't you gotta be prepared as a woman
today yeah with all this [ __ ] that you
read about [ __ ] it's like getting a DUI
today you come
mean save you I gotta stop talking
through the ladies days you're a
ninety-day personal suspension Uncle Joe
because I got everything available you
get an uber you lifted your rings you
know I'm saying lift just like the
bottom of the [ __ ] tier lift we'll
give you a ride for three dollars you
might have to blow the guy or you might
blow them and not know it till the
morning you wake up you wake up
somewhere but there's no option to have
a DUI not in today's society we have too
many options for you now to get a DUI if
you tell a bar that you're Hamid don't
figure it out I'll figure it out okay so
we can get people yes straight that they
can't they can't continue so how do you
know what the [ __ ] we're talking about
talking about that drunk lady past oh
yeah yeah and then her I have a daughter
I felt horrible looking at her but I was
about Pam my daughter never tha let her
guard down and I never get that's what
happened I did that in college at a
fraternity party and I asked this guy I
was like hey do you know where I can lay
down and then he gave me a room but he's
like make sure you lock the door behind
me and then it was like turns out he was
a nice guy like I'm the one chick in
college that found the one really nice
guy that must have had a ton of sisters
and he was like don't ever [ __ ] do
that again don't drink stuff out of the
garbage can at a fraternity house the
whatever
yeah whatever punch they're making and
never ask somebody if you can lay down
or you're gonna have just a pile of gang
rape we live in some weird [ __ ] times
now it's so weird that you could just
say something go for the median you're
done and you don't even have to get
arrested enough there's no proof
percentage you know I just remember this
when I lived in Colorado three I worked
with a guy at sport Kalin he was a
general manager I had extra cash because
I was robbing drug dealers cash in the
house in case somebody broke in and when
his father died and he didn't have the
true story he didn't have the money to
go home so I said take the money
you know we'll figure it out we always
he was always nice to me came back he
did pay me back but about three months
later he was a line judge and ski events
but he really said to tell sport Kaelin
the company because it was a conflict of
interest
not that they were doing anything wrong
he just felt there was nobody's business
yeah I'm saying some people just don't
need to know your business so he would
take off vacations like March 28 first
through the 29th then go to out of no
summit mountain and judge races or
whatever and he went to a bar on a
Monday on Tuesday if I'm saying this
correctly and he started talking to a
woman and they started a little cozy
bubble bob-bob but a girl that he had
slept with everybody was surrounding
then he went with that girl left him
went home was boom the next day he woke
up and went the ski thing that night
that girl that he had been talking to he
left at the bar the next morning she
went to the cops they said that she had
been raped by that guy what that he had
busted into the hotel room and raped her
that night so when they went to sport
Gailen to look for him they couldn't
find them and leave and look more
suspicious they like he took a vacation
where is he he didn't say so the cops
knocked on my door and they're like How
well do you know that I go he's my name
but we talked I have been easy I go what
is this concern like a while he's in
charge of them I go whatever it is I'm
not whatever but he ain't the type of
guy that yeah it's freaking Tony I
didn't know about rape yeah I didn't
know about the rape I didn't know so I
guess she positively identified him from
because they had no mugshot of them
you've never been arrested you got never
had a crossing ticket she identified him
from the door like boy you're the month
type pictures
whatever they do topsail look I know one
day I went outside maybe wasn't alone in
his car I go get in the [ __ ] house
what cops are looking for you for a rain
what are you talking did you meet some
chick they told me the whole story and
then he turned himself in
they got him arrested this chick swore
up and down the Bible how was done the
lock he had a mask on the ski mask so
they ran his house and find the mat they
did a hole right up in the [ __ ] paper
about it about him they use his name for
it oh yeah oh my god they bury them
spork down didn't know what to do me I'm
like this guy might smoke pot once in a
while whatever Blaine no [ __ ] tree
jumper small community and you know they
kept and then they the people were like
what are you talking about he had 800
witnesses he was a lot thinner ski
summit for four days or whatever it was
1983 guys when it came back they pressed
charges on him rape she was in Texas
they flew her back she identified him in
the whole thing and then he pulled the a
side of the car and he was like this is
why was this night this is where I was
the night before with this girl and they
chick said no I want to press charges
he's doing that rape me it was something
wild and he ended up going to court
witnesses and I got dismissed but then
there's a civil and he ended up suing
her for like defamation old something's
big in Texas
yeah but defamation and then before they
cut the check she came clean and said
that she had flown her boyfriend from
Texas and didn't want the parents to
know so the Maine had seen him going
into the room just [ __ ] people make
up
that's insane it was [ __ ] crazy
that's insane woman passed out yeah I
don't know I didn't I didn't take the
picture right
picture who they thought was funny that
she's armed she was all [ __ ] up by the
show and it was the second song she's
gonna wake up on so I know there was a
second song Jesus I could saw but it was
late when you posted that I figured it
was the end of the concert dirty know I
kept posting the pictures showing that
roses she's throw up a picture of us he
spell out one point she was this way on
the couch with a head back and then did
the boyfriend ever come back he came
back like an hour later all right and he
picked her up and she was like all
[ __ ] up and they just held and they
believe he loved it good guy what but I
was in post and picked his being [ __ ]
pervert no I was with my wife and me but
so I have a friend who like we're both
open-mike errs but she is on the road a
lot and she likes sleep in her car and
she got mad at me once because I was
like be careful I get me it like it made
me nervous to think about a friend of
mine sleeping in her car like a rest
stop and she's like you wouldn't say
that to a guy I'm like yeah but you know
I don't have any upper body strength as
a woman okay so as a woman comic a
female comic on the road did you ever
want into anything weird or my club
owners like he used to be like all right
why don't you let me pop you in the
[ __ ] like you just have to deal with
that [ __ ] for always for 10 years you
have no idea with these so much so I'm
like well that girl when I bring you
guys when I bring you guys with every
woman on the podcast it's because I love
you and it's basically out of respect
because nobody has women have a clue
yeah women know what workplace
harassment is and trust me unless it's
gonna be I want a blow job I want to
blow down
- tinium be joangel but as a comic you
know and listen any [ __ ] industry
where a woman starts at the low end of
the totem pole
there's always an [ __ ] and
something's always an [ __ ] flop you
know flexing his muscles for this poor
woman I'm sure I've done it when I was
younger but then you get sisters and you
have daughters and you meet women I mean
comic chicks are the coolest
[ __ ] if you like it I think
ever like I'm like if you fought the
battle like you'd be fighting every
[ __ ] day so eventually you just
learned to grow kind of a thick skin and
just ass is what it is you never I mean
what am I gonna do him in a battle dead
Craig glacier and Stanford thought he
dead died he died he died and I'm sad
because he owed me money yeah he was
super creepy but I feel like he had a
magic shell heart like he was one of
those guys that I do believe the in his
parents like four to have three drug
addict sons and that dad must have been
such a [ __ ] [ __ ] like I always had
a soft spot my heart for him
because I was like he was just a
fucked-up dude who wanted love and
attention all of them are gone all
brought all three of those brothers he
died right before my wedding and I cried
because he had owed me money and if I
had known he was dying he died of cancer
I wouldn't have asked him for my money
back and that was the one with the wig
yeah there's a lot of them with the wigs
but he was one of them really yeah
really bad the king of sting king of
sting the wig would stink come on under
the wig
you know listen I do calmly every
weekend not everything and I do comment
like every other weekend on the road and
it's very easy for me to take lead or
whatever but I was I refused because I
want him to see the beauty of Stan hmm
there's a whole thing it's not just
about getting onstage if you think it's
just about writing jokes and getting
onstage
quit now there's a whole culture of the
journey of getting better
journey of getting better than
of meeting people the journey of
understanding female comics hmm and how
they work with you you could work with
them you can want to get something it
could be a bad [ __ ] week you know I
love women opening for me you know why
because a lot of girlfriends by their
boyfriends tickets for me and then they
sit through another idiot in front of me
Kirsten I like to bring a woman so they
have something yeah so you know what I
don't like joke but at least I got a
broad that's drawing heat up to it women
are always I think the social planners
most copiers like my husband isn't a
planner puts on his pants and he kind of
goes where he's told but going back that
journey that journey is so important and
when I see a comic in LA and he thinks
he's at it and I know he didn't have
that journey that we had I know he's
gonna have to pay for it somewhere along
the line because those are the shows you
learn almost like bowling alleys this
sucks this is for one other every 15
that you get really good here but that
journey that journey is the one that you
cannot those vivid those rags I know you
know what it is to [ __ ] take a bus
yeah sitting from North Carolina at the
buffalo and every city you stop and you
have to go out and sneak to it so either
bus stop that stuff comes back later on
that's all I look at some of the things
I was willing to do like I remember
driving
I had a show and Ptolemais California it
was like seven half eight hour drive did
my show at this Indian casino for
whatever little money I was getting
drove back to the airport to fly to
Albuquerque didn't know that Roswell was
four and a half hours from Albuquerque
and then cried at the rental car place
because I was so [ __ ] tired and they
weren't gonna rent me a car because I
thought I was unstable and then I had to
convince them that I had a comedy show
that I had to get to and then they
rented me a car and I just remember
power.you a lot of powering through just
to like try and get it done and go and
pick up your hundred and fifty two
hundred bucks when you first start and
it's all you had
I feel it now when I go on stage in the
main room and I'm rocking and rolling
out there I go back I could say wow did
that work I did those Mormon homes and
Utah for triples partner you know it's
such a beautiful journey life is a
journey
well that was base it on one peg you
know that's what I liked about European
shows now it's like I'll do these weird
shows and like Rica
you know Croatia or Slovenia and I feel
like I'm new again because you have to
find that language barrier as to what
hits with another culture and I'm like I
haven't felt that sense of knew where
you like oh this is a barroom I'm doing
these weird bar shows and Croatia and
you you just not as good as you remember
being in the States because you there's
they just don't understand what the [ __ ]
you're saying half the time so you have
to kind of figure out comedy in a new
way you don't fifty-fifty now why is it
50/50 for your tour you doing 16 I'm
still touring more than I'm spending
time with my husband so what are you
doing I'm talking about percentages
estate to add a country ah no mostly
here like I'll come back I came back for
three weeks I'll go back for a week to
see my husband I'll come back for two
weeks I'll go back for two weeks to see
my husband I'll come back three weeks on
the road it'll go back just back and
forth between Italy and mostly shows on
the road like I'm hardly in LA just
every once a month maybe like three days
to whatever meetings and things I have
to catch up with check my mail how is
your experience with Netflix it's been
really good when did you shoot we shot
it in March and then it aired August 13
here in Los Angeles that's cool yeah and
you look at your felices years yeah
she's in my wedding yeah no [ __ ] in
Greece how long ago ah
one year ago we got married September
2nd so she could afford the green yeah
everybody we added a good turnout for
Greece 58 people for an intern effort
yeah some of his friends his friends are
a little shitty or than mine feel like I
got better friends this friend your
friends came out yeah and a lot of
friends
I had 14 bridesmaids for Pennsylvania
from Pennsylvania I had a few of my
teacher elementary school teacher
friends I feel I had friends from every
chapter of my life my college friends
friends I first met when I came out here
comedy friends I love you to death you
send an invite to your wedding I'm
coming yeah you can suck my dick you get
married at the VFW like the rest of the
girls in Pittsburgh do you I'm saying
everybody in Pennsylvania gets married
the via fire some fire do you want to
get married in Greece go [ __ ] you my
husband can't give him the kind of
Iranian passport I love it I love it
that you do all these adventurous things
if your life is really has been a
[ __ ] adventure no I forget sometimes
how cool it is I feel like my shitty
childhood afforded me a really good
adult life like you know as a female
come I think when people also get mad at
female comics I'm like you don't realize
what it took to become a female comic
like both my grandparents died of AIDS
my aunt shot herself in the face like
you don't become a lady comic if you've
had a whole bag of normal like you grew
up with homemade pudding and hugs you
know you had to take a few a few
beatings to become a lady comic then you
get more of them when you come in ah so
many I was saying listen I've seen a lot
of men come and go
mm-hmm but I've seen a lot of women come
and go and it's this just does something
to you and some of the women don't
realize like you're I got like 17 eggs
left yeah yeah we always have an ask for
sperm milk yeah the producer yeah
there's a lot of women I mean it's just
one day at 33 they've been doing comedy
for times and then I'm rocking and
rolling the overeat when the ovaries
call the ovaries call you know nature
calls
nature calls no and I'm not a lot of
women I bounce back on me now what do we
have we have four to five chicks that
shot specials pregnant yeah you know one
kid yeah I want a dollhouse and it feels
unstable as a woman to have a dollhouse
but you don't have a kid you can't just
be an adult woman with a dollhouse you
need you need that baby
hey I had 150 you did and she was 44
yeah all right all right
I still knocked her up at 44 we weren't
planning it you know they were talking
about it this morning at the gym they're
like you know you did it the right way
and I'm like I didn't do anything the
right one whoever controls this
[ __ ] world that that I didn't
know after 12 is after two years if I
don't get you pregnant it's loads the
heart I'm just shooting loathing it's a
[ __ ] falls out right or wrong when you
beat you closing you shut the toilet
turn off the light you come back three
days there's a little sea monkey how do
you save half of it because you shot the
other half of Mama's snatch yeah boy
yeah so I'm just asking you how do you
keep half of the other it's just the
back of your dick that's why you have to
pee after you have sex because in
between the suction your body
automatically wants to clean up whatever
that she has her dirty veg so you don't
get a UTI I know it's so weird what
people know about sperm like I don't
know I mean like sperm is don't we all
you need is one little aggressive little
guy that's it yeah oh yes it might load
your gallon and a half it was the size
of my nuts unfortunately have right now
I'm holding like two pipes right now I'm
a Python good mama snap in this
afternoon before we pick up yum-yum but
it's true like one little it's just I
didn't know this I learned I went to
prison they made you watch yourself they
showed all the black people before you
have kids watch these videos and [ __ ]
cuz I swear to God I was so racist they
made all the black inmates go to this
thing because it's necessary if you had
more than like 19 kids at one point
they're like we got it we got to explain
to you what happens maybe you're not
getting this the reason why you had this
was way before the term baby mama okay
you know there were guys in there I just
can't you know there's one man that
[ __ ] meet guys in jail come you like
a half the [ __ ] and get knocked up
all you needs a little bit and the
pressure that see what guys don't know
is when we're banging it yeah right we
start getting that little ticklish you
are you already shooting little
platelets of love to this fray
ejaculatory by the time you start
twitching yeah you pull it out you're
like ooh we missed it well give her a
minute look inside that little hole and
you'll see a little teardrop is a good
family is a family but I just love the
way you described a little ticklish a
little teardrop yeah what's going on
boys tell you styling yeah and you're
standing up you get that little
lightheadedness and all sudden you get
that little ticklish thing you already
came you've already pre-ejaculate Edyta
by the time you pull out and you see it
shooting in the air like oh yeah oh yeah
she's already got a little centimeter
that's swimming his way through yeah
that's not good
no so after three years to three years
of me date my wife I did not rob him
like he's never gonna happen
yeah so it's Lloyd's a ho ain't no
pulling out here shoot it you're gonna
walk a little funny little sleepy well
trapping little two hours at work you're
gonna feel like slipping out of your leg
I feel like my husband needs a baby
how old is judgment 34 okay so he's I
mean I've never met a deuteron like this
dude should be a dad because I've dated
comics were you like this this guy can't
be father of my child
this guy's weeping in his pillow every
night so this is the first stable dude
I'm like he needs a baby how happy not
that one the dog can be so I didn't know
that this is what it's like like he
literally asked me he's like what did
they do to you I'm like oh god I got
stories I got stories about these
animals I dated
I had a brief affair with a convict for
about six months yeah
oh we were uh I mean I had a dude who
[ __ ] a hooker in my room
we'd hooked up and then I didn't sleep
with him and then he we were in two
different rooms in Vegas and like he was
like I asked for my room key and then he
went downstairs and got a hooker and
[ __ ] her in my room after we made out
so I'm like I didn't even know that was
in the realm of possibilities of [ __ ]
that could happen and then I just took
like a Silkwood shower and cried and
then didn't date people for like a year
and a half after pretty bad comics just
glad I had a girl Rachel came early and
wolfson I think there's three power
couples not all right rich Ambani
recomand Christina Tom and Christina I
know that's that's a rarity yeah they
did it the right way or they planned
going out in a row you know it's why I
think when you start going on the road
together and you're involved together
that's what gets ugly it's too much
thank you if you're a comic and then you
become a TV writer and I'm a comic or
just a road comic I think it'll worked
yeah
if you have some sort of different thing
to pull from some different interest but
if we're both wrote couple comments you
and I both know and you could admit this
it's common its its Tara when you date a
comic after a while it's there a little
bit of a competition yeah of course or
especially I think as a woman like I've
dated comics where he just I'd come home
and he'd still not be on the road and
honest students just sitting on the
couch and I'm hurling my body every week
and my I'm tired my face is getting
tired and this [ __ ] just sitting on
the [ __ ] couch and I get up go and
try to get more work then they blame you
or you obsessed that's the thing that
started to scare me when I had my brief
encounter this was 98 it was it went
from us jack just having fun why do you
get those
I don't can't have it I can't have that
no my my husband just thinks it's cool
like he watched my special like he's
like it's better every time like it does
it really
he thinks it's neat and I've never had
that with a dude where there was no
level of competition he just thinks what
I do is cool he's encouraging and he
believes when I you know he has room to
believe because he doesn't if you're
comic and you have to like fight for
your own dreams but he doesn't have to
do that he has his own separate thing so
he can fight for me to have my dreams
that's where you [ __ ] me what's your
response been so far than that it's
pretty great all positive there's one
useless [ __ ] that hated me but I don't
know as far as the shows of people and
there yeah they're coming out which is
nice I feel like my numbers went up even
in tampon a hurricane my numbers were up
from the last year in size please yeah I
do side-splitter Club yeah do you do it
no I've never done oh okay no I like
side splitters I feel like the
independent clubs it's like I like when
you go back and the staff still the same
cuz at least there's some sense of
family
you're not as lonely I think or it like
the chain more corporate clubs I feel
like the turnover is high like I know
that I'd go back and it's always the
same dude at the bar or the same
waitress staff and he like you just know
what you're getting there's even that
even just going to different calmly
clothes and see him like I had a list
like when I was coming up there was a
comp a comic newspaper called just for
last and it came out of San Francisco it
was published by John Fox and it was a
bunch of comics who put your money where
your mouth is you say you want to be a
writer write me an interview every week
you went to view you read it to the
article but first a the comedy I'll
write an article about this and they put
a paper together but that's the last two
pages were every club state-by-state you
know you know Connecticut and you could
just circle the clubs
unable to play there you know I'll even
don't they have those listening well I
call the clubs and you don't really have
a list of all the clubs because they all
open and shut
yeah so quickly sometimes you know
you don't like the chains how I do I
mean like I like I like all of them I
don't really care if I like a club I
don't care if it's a chain in that no I
mean I don't care about that I just feel
like with the staff it feels more like a
family like if I go nice and worse you
know
three zing it's like well Burt Haase is
always gonna be there if I go to Tampa
it's always Bobby Jew like it's always
gonna be the same is Bert still there
yeah Bert's still there still dressing
up still has a pocket square still looks
fancy relationship with a different
comical club owners and I loved
featuring I really had a good time
featuring I wanted a lot yeah featuring
and I and I embraced it like most people
featured online yes three four years of
feature work three four years that's
perfect spot you're done no pressure you
got drunk chicks when they go to puke
either rub their back as they puke and
out Lulu come on I got a room to put you
in like that crap you know it's just
it's a different attitude you just go on
in to be a killer and some headline is
you're friends with and some are just
dicks yeah and some of on the borderline
and you get to see different comics and
what type of trauma do you want to be
like you know I got one of the memories
that sticks out in my mind today big
time comic opened up for him in Dallas I
went outside and there was a huge life
and I went back and I knew you know it's
like you flying out there for us [ __ ]
those [ __ ]
if I ever had learned yeah I would
definitely be out there with this is way
before pictures they just wanted to
shake your hand and we'll meet you you
didn't want to meet nobody I don't
understand that if they're coming out
you have to forget that like I feel like
people forget the people that come to
comedy shows that might be they might
have three kids that might be their
entertainment for the next three months
they might not get another break so how
dare be will when people are paying for
two tickets drinks maybe a babysitter
gas prices that might be their most
expensive evening out as a family like
that's their date night so you you're
there to entertain them that's what
bothers me about to show nights yeah
thanks
especially for me at all like to show no
just one not because now I do like
either comedy clubs or like medium
theaters yeah so sometimes they add a
second show and like New York sold on
June would you send round from Jersey
yeah it's gonna sell out so yeah the
second show but I don't like it because
the teaser doesn't want you gonna
because people trying to leave and then
people trying to get in and then they
try and take pictures and now you have
this madness like no walkie I did 420 I
felt terrible I did two shows I should
have done to show and that's what like
this week I'm in Chicago doing one show
why I want to sit there for an hour
afterward and Chaves make sure people
tape it I don't sell merch yeah I don't
sell merch because I don't want to take
them for everything they got yeah I
rather than come up to me and say hey I
didn't like the podcast with you and Lee
or the podcast help me or now I bought
the trick ticket
Florence this April Macy's got a
restaurant that you know I'm saying so I
don't want there to be a gap between us
and that I think that's all they're
looking for most of the time it's just a
human connection and I like that's what
kind of stand-up comedy is you have like
a groupthink mentality where people come
in and everybody's not kind on the same
team
to enjoy their night so when I shake
your hand and take a picture you that's
a completion of this journal mm-hmm
that's a completion though feeling
connected to you that's it yeah I put on
a podcast you listen to it one day
you've been accounted
I replied to you as a gentleman and now
we start a little dialogue in between us
we're not best friends but we
acknowledge each other on Facebook if
you put a picture you ugly get up I'll
say I put a picture of my as we get up
you say yeah and you really really and
then all sudden that person will say da
I see you're coming to Chicago
I live in whatever I'm doing the
two-hour drive and you meet him after
the show and you shake their hand and
you give them a hug and you take a
picture it's two minutes and it's
alright happy and that's it if the
people I come in and go can I ask you a
question about Joe Rogan get the [ __ ]
yeah can I ask you a question about
episode 22 or the podcast list and I
just did an hour on stage you know
yesterday I got a guy can you leave a
message of my phone I go why would I
want to do that I know if I do it for
you and I do if everybody else because I
won't tell nobody except the people that
call you you [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
idiot
you know I don't want to do cameo I
don't want to do none of that [ __ ] but I
want to meet people isn't done about it
I also feel like sometimes there's
audience members that you do really
connect with like in Tampa there was
this couples in a racial older couple
they were in their 60s and then they
would come every time I was there and
then he got sick he had brain cancer and
they weren't there for a few years and I
remember when they came back because he
got well I cry I'm like oh my god Frank
and there was something like so human
about it we're like oh I'm so glad to
see these audience members cuz I had
wondered every time I'd be like I wonder
if they're gonna come I wonder if he had
passed away and to see them back in the
audience was so satisfying and to know
he got through whatever illness he had
had and they were back to enjoying life
so you're like well that's nice it's
[ __ ] I'm still in all just seeing you
cuz I haven't seen you in so long it's
been Harris and I look at you and I
still remember you walking in one night
yeah like a little hat on ah
you won't like some little [ __ ] uh I
think it was like a French store this
dressed like an [ __ ]
like this just got the balls no oh I
just I just always loved your style and
how you uh it's great to see that you
still out there doing your thing Oh what
else would a comic anymore I got no life
skills this is it this is the only thing
I've ever been good at
what no look at me I dropped out I went
to University of Florida for two and a
half years and I was pretty [ __ ] up I
mean I had a bad weird childhood so
everybody died and then so when I was 17
my parents never let me do anything like
I was not equipped for life at 17 might
be dad was no no boys there was a lot of
like no boys and then I was just gobble
and wieners yes it was forbidden
they're just gobbling dick meet those
guys do you think that's just because I
have a daughter I think if you're really
overprotective like boys weren't allowed
to call my house my parents were married
really young and they had me on so I
think they just tried to prevent me from
making the same mistakes they did but in
doing that if you tell somebody you
can't have tangerines they're gonna want
to [ __ ] rub tangerines on their face
it's the same if men are forbidden
you're like give me all the and I had
abandonment issues from a lot of deaths
but then I was just gobble and we know
that deaths like my grandparents died my
aunt died like I just dealt with a lot
of a lot of tragedy as a kid so I think
when you have abandonment [ __ ] and it's
forbidden it was like the perfect
combination to just take all have all
the dicks just collect them don't do it
don't be overprotective with your
daughters there okay I thought of a
different world April so I'm very like I
know what the world is about yeah I know
who's out there
my wife is a little bit on the
whatever side I don't [ __ ] play you
know I'm raising the tower what we do
the podcast we do it
15-minute podcast I make it read a
homework assignment it's ten minutes but
the other 20 minutes I'm just talking so
on yeah I'm just saying those things to
it just so she knows I write every
journal every day I write oh you know in
the journal what I'm feeling I just
started writing about my life you know
trailing Saint that went to prison yeah
I don't want somebody town little wrong
[ __ ] yeah you got it from the horse's
mouth it's on paper yeah no this is my
second notebook so hopefully for some
jerk who says la on YouTube you should
he robbed the jewelry store I got the
proof fine yes jewelry store was a
liquor store you know [ __ ] you yeah yeah
that's really it's really sweet I think
that because of my exposure to I've been
exposed to you've been exposed to a lot
of things that you went home and said
Wow yeah what happened here what's wrong
what what what happened yeah what
happened data when you're especially
when you live in LA and you see how
people act and you see that the things
that people will do for fame or just for
a little bit of success you know like I
said it was a lot of I've only been with
like one comic maybe two or something
like that sexually but I have a lot of
comic friends his women and you look at
them and go they're my friends I got
that back no matter what
what something happens nothing happened
it's got nothing to do with me I'm not
gonna have I don't I don't need to do it
intervention I don't need to be that
much of a friend but I know that well I
think anything anybody that requires
that constant stream of validation it's
that's not a normal thing to want to
need like the constant nightly adoration
and love from somebody so you're like
well where didn't they get it early on
during the formative years like why do
you I mean
I know for me it's like I obviously
didn't have enough love growing up so
now I need it from everybody I meet
every audience every every fan you want
that adoration see for me I think I had
a parent I had I had a mother and a
stepfather who were an audience always
yeah like I'm not gonna sit you and tell
you I wasn't well I think with me my
comedy comes from the same place where
your Kaname comes from and it from being
pain and having to talk yourself off a
ledge all the time you know that's like
I'm very good at talking people off
ledges why because I've been on years I
talked myself let's just you know what
so edge Joey a tough time in your life
when you have to make a tough decision
when some people would just walk in tie
a knot yeah thank people would jump off
a building no and I feel like that was
my escape and so was the escape from my
parents like I feel like our house was
so filled with sadness that like I was
the pressure valve where I could like if
I could get a laugh out of somebody like
you didn't see that in the house like if
when people have AIDS when people are
like have mental illness like you're
constantly dealing with all of this pile
of [ __ ] if you can get somebody to smile
in their day so it was so satisfying
early growing up getting laughs out of
my parents because I don't think they
had a tremendous amount of happiness
themselves so I think that kind of
trickles into adult life now people have
hard lives that's why I think you see
comedy or people write you the most
satisfying thing is when it's people
arriving laughed in months to know
somebody else was going something
through something tragic and they
connected enough with you paid their
entertainment dollar and you gave them a
little release from that pain for a
little bit I think is a really beautiful
thing people should everybody's just
like comics just April Maisie calm April
Macie on social media ma CIE they can
find me on Tiffany Haddish presents they
ready streaming on Netflix and just
driving around town that's fine I'm
happy you didn't jump off a plane oh
thank you
did you know women showed no no me and
Ida Ida and I were going to do that
today we're gonna take toward you land
first and lay on their backs way to fall
on their decks they were all gonna lay
and see we got lucky Jeffrey's Martine
Moreno Titus Titus go I don't I didn't
want to go I felt like I need to get
past beers in my life like what time are
we doing it at one o'clock the only
problem is I have mercy as whatever the
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah I was gonna jump out
of a plane so it was I have to get over
there but you know no want to sell
tickets do this if you want to be me
everyone Jeff I don't plane join the
[ __ ] Air Force thank you for riding a
bike there's no way because I'm so
scared I wanted to do it did you
Speirs in life like I feel certain
boundaries that like keep you held to
hold you back I'm like well either I die
or I've just worked past a fear next
I'll get into a tank with a shark or
something it was funny because this
morning I was thinking about you when I
went on because I went I got up school
breakfast and then I went somewhere then
I got back and I went on Twitter and I
saw the pictures so I had to go to the
bathroom and when I was walking to the
bathroom
I was thinking about what the [ __ ] would
happen like I would love to jump off a
plane like I can't believe I said
something to her yeah about going on a
plane because why didn't see I'll either
side well we were gonna do it together
we were kinda to lady hand holders and I
said you know what
hide something I always wanted to do I
just I gotta do it with the right beat
Golden Knights I feel like if you're
gonna jump you might as well jump with
army dudes who are jumping all the time
oh do Bronston jones do that
I don't know a couple beers yeah well
yeah but I think Bronte he did with the
army lost a little bunch of weight over
the past month he didn't pull the
[ __ ] Leon the zip line people with
the zip line same thing they make you
wait cut damn it don't be bullshitting
yeah that's him to me real quick before
we got some time you have any dates
coming up I do I'm this weekend I'm in
with Tiffany Haddish at the Indiana
University auditorium with Ida and
Shantae I'm at rooster T feathers in
Sunnyvale and then I met penguins and
that [ __ ] place still open I don't
know what his name is he was uptight he
didn't want to pay Jeff Johnson is dead
he's still there oh my god I will be in
Chicago this weekend at the Chicago
theater there's still a few tickets left
October 11th the Uptown Theater in
Kansas City and Denver the second show
has been added at the Paramount tickets
are still available real [ __ ] quick
let me just mention the sponsors and
I'll get you [ __ ] out of here
right the Church of what's happening now
is brought to you today by upstart most
of us find out the hard way that getting
into debt is easy getting out of debt is
hard especially if your credit cards if
your credit score isn't great they offer
you smaller interest rates to help you
pay off your credit that that's what
upstart does all right upstart goes
beyond the traditional credit score your
upstart interest rate is based on your
education and your job history
not just your credit score they actually
reward you for going to school so
upstart doesn't care about the bills
you didn't pay five years ago they care
about the person you are now
today and they give you a rate based on
that plus they make it fast simple easy
to check your rate in just a few minutes
without affecting your credit score and
the best part is you're ready once the
loan is accepted most people get their
funds the very next day the next day
over three hundred thousand people
reviews
start to pay off credit card school
loans or to fund their weddings in
Greece and to make large purchases free
yourself from the burden of high
interest click credit card debt today by
consolidating everything into one
monthly payment will up stars it's that
easy
I'm telling you this is the way to go
see why upstart is ranked number one
there category with over 300 businesses
on Trustpilot hurry up start calm / Joey
again up start calm / Joey listen if
you're in debt you got to start
somewhere I had to start with one of
these things about 20 years ago after my
divorce so please go to up start over
300,000 people have used up start they
are number one in their category so
please I'm start calm / Church to find
out how low your up start rate is
checking your rain only takes a few
minutes and it will not it will not
affect your credit that's upstart calm /
church the church is also brought to you
by are you ready listen to me you ever
call your bookie he's not around or he
gives you a higher line let's say you
live in New England Boston and you go to
bed no England online there's always
gonna be higher in that area because
there's more fans that [ __ ] stops today
listen we're going on week 3 week 3 work
week [ __ ] 4 and you're still telling
me you went to and I waited and when it
died well if you find 100 hours in the
street when you walk past it or would
you pick it up yeah you pick up the [ __ ]
up so why do you keep picking winners
and not bet them listen go to my bookie
it's fast it's easy and they pay when
you win let's face it where you're
betting is just as important as who
you're betting on so if you're trying to
bet the NFL baseball UFC Bellator MMA
whatever my bookies got it I wouldn't be
telling you guys to bet with them if
they want to [ __ ] the best a'right so do
the smart thing if you got a bet this
football season college football the
[ __ ] playoffs are coming in baseball
don't
series there's a fountain of money
coming your way
1-800 gambling if you have a gambling
problem if you're that kind of guy who
likes to bet a little win a lot try a
parlay if all your picks come true you
multiply your winnings and no matter how
you bet the NFL season is the best time
of the [ __ ] year I tell you what I'm
gonna do here double your deposit right
now today use promo code Church CH you
are CH to get 100 percent bonus on your
initial deposit up to $1,000 you put 500
in we give you a nickel you put a
hundred we give you a heart are your
yardstick visit my bookie dot AG tight
that's my bookie dot AG and don't forget
to use promo code Church CH you are CH
when creating your account to claim the
bonus my bookie you play you win you get
paid and listen check Instagram tomorrow
I'm dropping a video with my one pick in
a week I'll teach you how to place the
bets on my bookie you'll be saying uncle
Joey's a [ __ ] savage catch me on
instagram on my for a mad flavor world
I like that [ __ ] I love you
[ __ ] don't forget honors
running the contest 30 count 90 count
alpha brain or the powder you got a
raffle ticket details on Monday for all
you [ __ ] I love you don't
forget to support April Macie she's a
[ __ ] Savage I got none of my respect
for it she's hung in this [ __ ]
she's taking slowed shots to the face
you don't know she still shows up to the
dance and I'm very happy you married I'm
prettier than ever you're always welcome
to visit us and for you [ __ ] I
love you I'll be seeing Bablu Lingus and
Josh from 10th planet and all my boys
Friday in Chicago at the Chicago theater
8 o'clock Kate Quigley and beam down ray
I'll be there [ __ ] around so I'll see
you [ __ ] then have a great week
have a great weekend and I'll see you
for Rosh Hashanah happy Rosh Hashanah to
the Jewish community
you guys and don't forget 1-800 gambler
kick this [ __ ] me Oh Lee